hey mike well steve carr said he's still
good with the energy the fourth the pace
his warriors are playing with but he
said the one thing they have to do
better is move the ball he said we just
had seven assists in that first half
guys are playing so hard
[Applause]
wiggins looking to post update him
curry launches a three that's good
that's what steve kerr was so upset with
in game three so we just didn't box out
they got crushed on the boards
and here's the shot we're talking about
you're right robert williams gotta
affect steph curry coming off that
screen but good job by derrick white
fighting over the screen and contestant
lineup
[Applause]
and maybe some second shots
curry again oh steph curry from way down
down he's furious that's a ridiculous
shot
no why don't you concentrate on al
hoffman he should be up that guy he's
amazing oh my goodness
that was all created that space by an
excellent cut by tatum
curry to payton
payton at all time in the world curry
three-pointer puts it in
33 for steph curry
curry fakes
smart nearly takes it away
and curry will bring it back out smart
harassing
[Applause]
curry now has williams on him looking to
unload it
flips it up shot is good that the
warriors can beat the green and white in
boston well
that point god did
that's steph curry getting on the
offensive end
they've had some good looks but the
threes won't go down as curry comes the
other way
[Applause]
turry degrees
[Applause]
[Music]
back to curry step back three-pointer
bang
steph curry was able
to get just enough room from white
to knock in another incredible shot